لحظه حرجه في محطه وقود بكارولاينا
الشماليه فال الشرطي شون جروبر توقف بجانب
رجل شاهدوا ما الذي حدث بعد
ذلك عندما التف الرجل الى سيارته لاخراج
الرخصه اطلق الشرطي النار عليه بشكل
فوري
الضحيه البالغ من العمر 35 عاما بقي على
قيد الحياه اما الشرطي جروبر فتعرض للطرد
واتهم
بالاعتداء وفي بينز ب مونتانا اقترب شرطي
من اربعه اشخاص داخل
سيارتهم ويبدو ان الشرطيه جرانت موريسون
تعرف على احدهم حيث اشتبهت الشرطه بتورطه
في حادثه اطلاق نار بوقت سابق الشرطي قال
للشخص بانه يثير قلقه ثم حدث
الاتي الرجل الذي قتل كان اعلا لكن الشرطي
موريسون قال انه خشي على حياته لان الرجل
استمر بانزال يده اليسرى رغم تحذيرات
الشرطي له برفع يديه وتم الحكم بان حاله
القتل كانت
مبرره اما في اريزونا فقد صورت كاميرا
الشرطي تايلر ستيوارت اخر لحظات حياته بعد
محادثه اعتياديه بينه وبين رجل مشتبه به
في حاله عنف منزلي الشرطي ستيورت لم يكن
يمسك بمسدسه لكن شاهدوا ما الذي حدث عندما
طلب تفتيش
الرجل
الفيديو ينتهي هنا مع اخراج المشتبه به
مسدسا من جيبه مطلقا ست رصاصات على الشرطي
الذي لم تكن لديه فرصه للبقاء على قيد
الحياه الشرطي قضى في المستشفى اما
المشتبه به فاستخدم سلاح الشرطي لقتل
نفسه